a time for celebration but also a time
of increased danger as the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast or Good
Friday agreement looms a stark reminder
that the peace had secured remains a
fragile one the security service MI5
today raised the terror threat in
Northern Ireland to severe meaning an
attack there is highly likely the psni
supported by Partners will relentlessly
pursue those who seek to cause harm and
terrorize our community and those who
seek to attack police officers and other
members of the security services here in
Northern Ireland the Northern Ireland
secretary tried to strike a reassuring
tone the public should remain Vigilant
to put not alarmed he said and continue
to report any concerns they have to the
Police Service of Northern Ireland MI5
doesn't explain its decisions but the
move comes a month after the attempted
murder of DCI John Caldwell and Omar the
shooting suspected to be the work of the
new Ira the detective from remains in
critical condition
and it comes on the brink of a visit to
Ireland North and South by President Joe
Biden as the U.S leader marks the
anniversary of Northern Ireland's peace
agreement
Security Experts don't think the
presidential visit plans will be
affected by the increased Threat Level
nor that an attack is now inevitable
there is a small but reasonably potent
group of terrorists who would be intent
on using the opportunity to Garner
attention for themselves when the
world's gaze would be in Ireland so with
that awareness MI5 would have had no
choice but to take this this is prudent
precaution taking as opposed to a knee
jerk reaction Northern Ireland of course
has been here before the Threat Level
was at severe for 12 years from 2010 to
just last year it was reduced to
substantial just over 12 months ago
after decreased levels of dissident
Republican activity now it's back to the
second highest Threat Level Possible A
lot has changed in Northern Ireland in
the last quarter Century but some things
have not the threat of violence from
those supposed to be consigned to the
past still lingers and will cast a
shadow over the celebration of Peace
Stephen Murphy Sky News